i've got kids and i can never convince
them that anything i do is cool
that's got to be different for you right
it's got to be different
you know what um in the beginning when
they were younger because my son's first
words were
wu-tang my first son that's fantastic
right
but as they got older and you know we're
living in this millennial era now and
they're more uh
they need to have it now instant
gratification i don't think they think
i'm as cool as i used to be so now i
have to remind them like you know
i people love me all over the world i'm
pretty famous you know what i mean it's
like
you guys have no idea like y'all should
respect me you should
be bowing at my feet right now yeah that
is a
big deal but you know what it doesn't
work that way
it doesn't have nah nah not at all to
them you're just dead
you know dads are never cool past a
certain point
but what about let's say you're walking
down the street back when we could all
walk down the street and you see
someone walk by wearing a wu tang clan
t-shirt because those are everywhere and
the the the logos everywhere
do they get do they get do they give you
the respect
then you know what that's funny that you
brought that up because
i recently passed somebody on the street
with a wu-tang t-shirt on
i mean like passed right by them and
they didn't speak to me
what they had no idea i was mean but i
get it i get it
because i could be wearing i don't know
a judas priest shirt only
person i know from judas priest is the
lead singer if i saw him i could pick
him out of the lineup
the drummer the bass guitarist the
guitarist they could be standing right
next to me i wouldn't even
know and i'd have that t-shirt on yeah
that's happened to me
i've passed people on the street that
are wearing a conan t-shirt
and they stop me and they say excuse me
ma'am do you know where the coffee shop
is
so i've i've been there
most people think i'm an uh older french
woman they just have no idea